and how this translates into skillbank's
brand
is our videos are motivating content
we're showing zero to hero stories we're
showcasing our students we're showing
inspiring content to get people to
realize that they can take their own
path and put their life into their own
hands
after you have defined what you want
your brand to look like
and who you are trying to serve your
content to you want to identify
seven to eight creators that are within
your space that are creating content
that is hitting the audience that you
want to hit
and you're going to use these creators
to help you
to define the trends that you should be
creating content around
what you're going to see on tick tock is
they have a they have a search page
where you can see
content that's trending that is going to
be no help to you when it actually comes
to building your brand on tick tock
because what is growing on the platform
as a whole
is not going to actually be maybe what
your niche is watching so that's why you
want to look to those seven to eight
creators that are creating content for
your audience
and copy their trends and make those
their trends your own
so different trends to be looking out
for there's advice content
sandy lynn with small business tips is a
really good example of this
where her content is a lot of pointing
and showing different types of pieces of
advice
there's haley hoffman smith that's
creating storytelling content
her content's all around manifesting and
sharing her story about how she's trying
to become a talk show host
and then we have pick and peel stones
and this is a product
and they have lava rocks that they put
latex into
and it's for people that have
dermatillomania
and they're just showcasing how their
product works and
where you can buy it for skill bank we
were following
a few creators that were prominent in
the marketing space
and in the entrepreneurial space and
then in the life manifestation space so
naturally sandy lynn with small business
tips was an account that we were looking
for
to get ideas from follow mario is
another example of a creator that we
were taking a look at he is a marketing
executive
at h m and he also gives career advice
to people that are looking to break into
the marketing space
and then lastly we really liked haley's
content because she has that
storytelling element that not a lot of
tick talkers have
and she's also talking a lot about how
to chase
your life path and make a life for
yourself
so this is just an example of how we
took
trends that we were seeing and we
started to make it our own
so we saw sandy was creating a lot of
pointing content we saw mario was doing
the same thing
so we decided to do something very
similar and a lot of our content is just
using this formula